hiya dr kutz hello david how are you
doing i'm doing well i'm excited to
learn about this thing we call the cold
war what is a cold war and what makes it
different than a hot war
so a cold war and in this case it's
really um
it might be a term that we could debate
is a war where the two major combatants
never actually fire bullets at each
other or drop bombs on each other so
never in the course of the cold war
did the us
ever meet to ground troops with the ussr
but people still died in combat right
okay so the cold wars kind of fought
through proxy wars and these are wars
that are taking place
in other nations developing nations of
the world
where the u.s is supporting one side
generally the the pro-capitalist side
and the soviet union is supporting the
other side a communist side so this
is the case in the korean war in the
1950s and then definitely the case in
the vietnam war in the 1960s so the u.s
and the ussr aren't fighting directly
but they're kind of betting on boxing
matches betting on different fighters in
the same boxing match yeah but they're
not just betting they're also uh putting
money and
arms where their mouth is so you know if
they're they're two different fighters
in the ring you know the us is is given
the the capitalist fighter
it's feeding him so you've got the
capitalist fighter in one corner and you
know he's sweaty and he's beaten but the
u.s is behind him with like a towel and
one of those like water buckets flashing
water in his face like get in there
sparky get in there right and if
necessary you know uh you know tying up
his boxing glove maybe giving him a new
pair of shoes
um and you know doing whatever they can
paying his rent right doing everything
that they can meals probably right
that's the marshall plan exactly okay so
tell me tell me about these two
components in this in this corner
wearing a wearing wearing a suit
is harry truman and harry truman is the
president of the united states uh
starting in 1945 he was vice president
to franklin roosevelt uh who had been
the u.s as president since 1932
and who tragically died uh in 1945 so so
truman is really in charge of ending
world war ii for the united states and
also kind of
setting a post-war plan so he he
prosecutes the end of the war he makes
the decision to drop the atom bomb on
nagasaki and hiroshima
and he ends the war in both theaters
right okay
and
and in the other corner wearing a very
fine mustache
is joseph stalin and he's uh the soviet
premier uh he's been in charge since the
1920s
and for him
i would say the most important thing
that stalin wanted after world war ii
was
security shall we say um
so if you're if you remember your
history in world war one
germany invaded russia in world war ii
germany invaded russia oh i'm seeing a
pattern and if there's anything that
stalin wants
in the post-1945 era it is not to be
invaded by germany anymore sure so he is
very anxious to make sure
that the world is safe for communism um
he
thinks that
the best way to make sure that
russians can continue the
experiment and the revolution of
communism
is to have a buffer zone
shall we say between
russia and the rest of europe okay
and he does that by kind of shoring up
some puppet governments
in what we now call the eastern bloc
these uh these nations that
had been taken over by hitler
and then when the soviet union joined
the war on the side of the allies then
were re-taken over by russia as they
fought hitler back so a lot of a lot of
those central european countries like
hungary and and lithuania and the former
czech czechoslovakia former yugoslavia
and he has the advantage of having boots
on the ground there right because he'd
beaten back hitler's invasion eventually
russian troops who are fighting against
hitler and american troops who are
fighting against hitler uh you know they
meet in berlin at the fall of of hitler
and kind of shake hands in berlin
but the advantage that russia has is
they've got a lot more people here
they've got uh you know most of
europe now
at least
east of berlin
has soviet troops on the ground sure
so kim you had been telling me that the
soviet union did yeoman's work in
containing and
basically prosecuting the entire eastern
front during world war ii yeah and you
know the soviet union actually lost 20
million people
during world war ii that's
i mean just a ludicrous number um they
lost more than anyone except for china
and germany
so i feel like they have they feel like
they have a real stake in the outcome of
world war ii
so at the end of this what what is what
is the situation in the ussr like
they've conquered all of this territory
but are they are they strong enough
economically to hold all of it and feed
everyone
no not really um in fact most of europe
is in pretty dire straits if you think
about it
all of
world war ii was really kind of fought
right right here right in the european
bread basket and so
there is serious economic trouble uh in
the aftermath of world war ii
um you know people don't have enough to
eat
they certainly don't have any cash
and they don't have any fuel which is
very worrisome in 1946 because that's a
terrible winter so people are
cold and they are hungry
and
uh when people are cold and hungry there
is a lot of
fuel for a possible revolution sure
right uh you even in in the 1930s right
in the united states there's a lot of
different political ideas that come up
during the great depression because when
your political system isn't working well
you consider other kinds of political
systems so the united states is worried
that because of the cold winter of 1946
and scarcity across western europe this
blue part of the map is going to turn
much redder right so for the united
states they're worried that
communism uh is kind of the the child of
of hunger and and poverty okay and
they're afraid that because stalin has
so much territory in europe that he is
really
well poised to become hitler part two
okay that is a sequel the united states
does not want to see no absolutely not
and if they really learned anything from
world war ii it's that appeasement
doesn't work okay right um during the
1930s
uh many people in the west
uh the
prime minister of uh of england neville
chamberlain kind of felt like they
didn't want to go back to war right
because world war one was still very
much on people's minds in the 1930s
and so they figured you know let's let's
not confront hitler head on
because you know we're not up for that
right now we're also in the middle of a
worldwide depression
um and that helped nothing because it
just meant that hitler could gain a
whole lot of territory and world war ii
was much worse than it might have been
um if they hadn't gone after hitler
earlier and stopped the unschloose yes
if you stop the onscleus you stop the
onslaught
exactly so um so they're really trying
to say all right stalin if he wants to
could probably just
run his way through the rest of europe
right uh with very little resistance
okay because the only nation in the
world that has the military and economic
power to stop the soviet union is the
united states because their factories
and fields were not bombed to cinders
during the european theater right so if
they want to stop hitler part
the stalin years
right then they're going to have to
really stand up for
capitalism and also for the kind of
material comforts and
democratic what we call
self-determination
right this is one of the
the most important ideas to come out of
the alliance between the united states
and britain which is that the citizens
of a region should have the right to
decide their own form of government okay
and they think of
the soviets as being totalitarians and
that's not a
wrong assessment because there is a very
strong totalitarian control coming out
of moscow in the soviet union
so they say if we're going to keep
europe from turning all red all
communist then we're going to need to
kind of shore up europe okay you know
they think of communism as kind of being
a little bit like a flood
should we say that you've gotta you
gotta put sandbags
around
the edges of communism otherwise it's
gonna leak out
uh so is the united states and their
allies also interested in creating their
own kind of light blue buffer zone
also next to the eastern bloc or are
they interested in is this is this when
we get to the creation of nato
nato really comes out of an
understanding that world war ii has not
created peace okay and so the u.s is
going to have to
forego their you know more than a
century-long commitment to being
isolationist
and
take a stronger role in the world so
okay so for the folks at home what does
nato stand for uh atlantic treaty or
north atlantic treaty organization
and this is a uh it's a defensive
alliance between
at first 12 nations
which say
that
an attack on one is will be treated as
an attack on all gotcha well that sounds
like they're maneuvering their boxers
into position and like rubbing the
shoulders and getting them ready yes
very much so and i think one of the
tragedies of
the the post-war era is that maybe
things didn't have to be like this right
after
the us and the ussr had worked together
to defeat hitler
it might have been possible for them to
coexist peacefully
but i think they both had the idea that
the other economic system and we're
talking about communism and capitalism
which is kind of riddled with internal
inconsistencies and that eventually the
world would be all capitalist
or all communists
and they were going to have to really
marshal all of their resources behind
their chosen boxer or they were going to
lose
sounds like a fight that's going to take
a long time
and it did end round one